[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous emmène avec moi on
part à la découverte des de randonnée
des Yvelines et pour commencer cette
escapade on part à la rencontre d'une
association de randonnée de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline c'est
[Musique]
parti bonjour je m'appelle Pascal Wagner
je suis le président d'une association
de randonné qui s'appelle la
DAL
[Musique]
on a différentes niveaux de randonnée ça
commence à 3 km pour aller jusqu'à 25 km
alors 3 km on est là sur ce qu'on
appelle des randau santé c'est-à-dire ça
s'adresse à des personnes qui sont en
insuffisance cardiaque ou respiratoire
ou des gens qui ont des fractures et qui
veulent se remettre à marcher
régulièrement donc là entre 3 et 6 km on
fait euh un parcours complètement à plat
sans
[Musique]
déniveler ensuite on va dans le domaine
de ce qu'on appelle la promenade une
promenade facile par exemple c'est 7 km
et 100 m de dénivelé ou une promenade
modérée là ça a beaucoup de succès le
mercredi matin par exemple on fait une
11 11 10 km au-delà si on veut marcher
plus on appelle ça des randonnées donc
c'est sur la journée avec un pique-nique
le mardi par exemple il y a des
randonnées de 17 km avec 2 300 m de
dénivelé le jeudi on va jusqu'à 20 25 km
avec 4 600 m de dénivelé et le dimanche
on alterne 17 25 km et cetera tous les
animateurs de l'association des arcades
du lac sont diplômés par la Fédération
Française de Randonnée il propose
également des randonnées à faire sur
plusieurs jours alors si vous êtes
intéressé n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de votre votre écran et si vous
voulez tester la randonnée
tranquillement dans les ivelines Pascal
Wagner nous donne de randonné à faire
pour cet
automne la première je vous incite
vivement à utiliser une application qui
s'appelle Marando c'est une application
qui est faite par la Fédération
Française de randonné si vous avez
l'habitude de randonné vous retrouverez
le format de ce qu'on appelle les topog
guides vous pouvez rechercher un circuit
qui va se retrouver donc par exemple à
Proxim limité ou faire une recherche par
département bon par exemple ici le le
nombre que vous voyez indique le nombre
de randonnées à proximité et en zoomant
vous pouvez choisir une ou plusieurs
[Musique]
randonnées donc c'est une randonnée qui
est plutôt urbaine on voit aussi des
curiosités ou des des sites particuliers
de de la région il y a les sculptures de
martapan il y a des les sculptures qui
s'appelleent des guetteteurs près d'un
lac il y a les S de la Bièvre différents
points d'intérêt qui sont euh agréables
et que l'on ne connaît pas forcément
même si on passe bien souvent pas loin
et bien c'est parti je me trouve à la
gare de Saint-Quentin en Yveline on part
pour une boucle de
3h première ville nouvelle à avoir reçu
le label ville et pays d'art et
d'histoire Saint-Quentin en Eveline
bénéficie d'un patrimoine
particulièrement riche et diversifié
d'ailleurs on tombe tout de suite sur
les premiers points d'intérêt comme ici
avec le repas des géants un clat d'œil à
la proximité du lycée hôelier cette
œuvre a été réalisée en
1982 par l'artiste allemand close Schulz
à quelqu pas le parc des sources de la
Bièvre qui s'étend sur 60 hactares il
nous offre un magnifique kamailleeux de
jaune d'orange et de
[Musique]
rouge
en continuant notre circuit on tombe sur
le quartier des templettes de voisin le
Bretonneux et le quartier des arcades du
lac de Montini le Bretonneux conçu par
Ricardo beauofil ils font partie
intégrante du patrimoine architectural
de Saint-Quentin en Nline entre les deux
vous retrouverez le bassin de la
Sourderie qui matérialise la limite des
deux communes un endroit ressourçant où
les canards ont élu domicile loin du
tumulte de la
[Musique]
ville on a bientôt terminé notre boucle
je suis revenue à l'entrée du parc des
sources de la Bièvre juste derrière moi
la fameuse œuvre de martapan alors si
vous aussi vous êtes adepte de
l'architecture n'hésitez pas à vous
attarder devant l'église Saint-Quentin
les sources la halle Marcel prou la
place George pomidou ou encore le
théâtre de Saint-Quentin en Eveline
cette première randonnée était très
agréable moi ce que j'ai préféré c'est
le mélange entre la nature la ville et
le patrimoine architectural en plus on
ne salit pas trop ses chaussures et ça
c'est important de le souligner les
parcs les arbres les étanss ont de très
jolies couleurs en automne après cette
première découverte j'ai hâte de voir la
deuxième randonnée que va nous
conseiller Pascal Wagner alors une
seconde rononé qui s'appelle à la
découverte du Val de Gali là on est
plutôt sur le domaine élargie du château
de Versailles où le Roi Soleil voulait
avoir de grandes étendues pour ses
chasses et surtout avoir une perspective
donc en fait au-delà du parc de Château
de Versailles qui s'arrête à la ferme de
galille le domaine allit beaucoup plus
loin à l'époque là donc on est dans
cette régionl où on peut avoir parcourir
des des paysages un peu
[Musique]
typique
il y a un magnifique moulin à reine
moulin il y a des belles perspectives on
a une partie en forêt une partie dans
les champs et là on est un petit peu
plus long puisqu'on est sur 15 km ça se
fait plutôt dans les 4 He ça et bien
c'est reparti je vous emmène avec moi
pour cette deuxème randonnée lieu de
départ la gare de noisil lenois qui se
trouve juste derrière moi vous pouvez y
accéder en voiture vous voyez il y a un
parking ou alors avec le t33 qui
relissin sur l'école à Saint-Germain en
lait aujourd'hui on a de la chance on a
un beau soleil d'automne on va pouvoir
bien
profiter après quelques kilomètres de
marche on tombe sur l'allée royale
imaginé en 1680 par André Le NRE elle
relie Villepreux au château de
Versailles et elle offre de jolie balade
et ben je suis pas toute seule à me
promener à affronter le vent sur ce
chemin de randonnée qui est vraiment
magnifique ça fait du bien de se
promener avec un paysage à perte de vue
comme ça des champs à perte de vue je
vous conseille vraiment cette
[Musique]
randonnée ça souffle ça
souffle j'ai plus de
[Musique]
coiffure après avoir parcouru une bonne
partie de l'allée royale on arrive au
charmant village de reen moulin ici
plusieurs points sont à découvrir comme
l'ancien moulin construit sur le Rud
Gali à partir du 13e siècle le village
s'est développé autour de ce moulin et
de la chapelle Saint-Nicolas un peu plus
loin on arrive sur le lavoir du village
toujours en bon état qui recueille les
eaux de
[Musique]
pluie en traversant les champ juste
après reine moulin on parvient à la
ferme des moulinau et de pantali ces
fermes datent aussi du 13e siècle et
sont liés à l'installation de Moulins
sur les rues de Gali et de maltout en
continuant notre route on tombe sur la
ville de BI on passe à côté du château
de baahi qui fut construit en 1526
aujourd'hui le domaine propose des
programmes de rééducation pour les
enfants
handicapés et voilà on termine notre
balade à noisis-lereroi là aussi on
passe devant le château de la commune
avec ces deux statues de chien de chasse
qui nous rappelle que nous sommes sur
l'ancien domaine de chasse des rois de
France avant de regagner la gare on
passe par le parc de la roserie un
endroit tranquille où on peut se reposer
après cette longue
[Musique]
balade c'est connu c'est de lutter
contre la sédentarisation il y a un
dicton qui dit une journée de randonnée
c'est une semaine de santé et comme on
dit ben à bientôt sur les
chemins
[Musique]